Kriss oil has taken a dive down to a
penny a barrel and it's dragging the
stock market down today as we sit here
it's exciting a penny Dave I don't
recall that happening I haven't gone
back and looked at any historical data
but I am I just emotionally don't recall
that happening ever and I think it's a
good time to stop and use this as an
example a it'll be fine it's temporary
why did it drive the why's that drive
the stock market down because it affects
Exxon it affects Mobil it affects all
the big oil stocks and they're part of
the Dow Jones Industrial Average so the
markets down as we're sitting here right
this second by 500 points and losing a
little bit of ground it had regained as
people started gaining confidence that
someday this whole thing's going to be
over with the corona of our shut down
but here's the lesson folks oil is a
commodity why is its price dropped a
commodity works like this a simple in
seventh grade you should have been
taught this but some of you weren't hmm
it's called a supply demand curve and a
when supply crosses demand that's where
price is established and so it's if you
think of an x1 going wonder of one line
going one direction one line going the
other direction that's a standard supply
demand curve now what this sounds like
is common sense if you think about it if
there is a huge oversupply of things
prices go down if there's a shortage of
things based on the demand when it's the
only way there would be an overage or
surety that's right is based on demand
then prices go up okay so why is oil
down everyone's sitting at home tada
you're not supposed to be out there
driving your car and so the largest
consumer of gasoline in the world the
largest consumers of gasoline in the
world the developing countries are the
developed countries if we call them that
the United States of America by far the
largest China the second and the United
States of America sitting at home do and
so
consumption isn't you know there's a
huge over supply you're the old saying
you can't give it away right and they're
trying at a penny a barrel to give it
away now translation is that should show
up in gasoline prices after it's refined
after the oil is refined in 30 to 90
days you should see some of that happen
the oil prices also douve when Russia
got an argument about oil with Iran a
few weeks ago you guys remember that it
was in the news it was way down below
all the quran of coronavirus panic stuff
but it was in the news and what happened
was is they couldn't come up the cartel
says we're going to control the spigot
we're going to control the supply and
we're always going to have enough of a
shortage that we keep the price up there
so we turn the spigot down and don't let
as much out or we let a little more out
Makia they control the price with the
supply based on worldwide demand what
they couldn't control was that worldwide
demand came to a screeching halt and
russia and iran getting this little
argument and decide to throw a bunch of
oil on the market so we've got double
dips on extra supply supply on supply on
supply on supply and supply and so it
would be like if we over built houses
and there were houses sitting everywhere
for sale and there were no buyers
guess what house prices would do welcome
to 2008 that's right they went down yes
so commodities our homes are a little
different but commodities like oil alone
around the stock market this is why we
tell you not to buy gold okay the the
demand for it drives the price and that
not the actual oil doesn't actually
create money mm-hmm the barrel of oil
doesn't it eventually does once it turns
into gasoline and our an oil refined
product of some kind but the barrel of
oil is traded based on supply and demand
gold is traded based on supply and
demand and there's a higher demand when
people are greedy or afraid for gold and
that's the only thing that drives gold
prices versus a share of dáil or a share
of mcdonald's stock or sheriff home
depot stock or a rental property
actually creates money mm-hmm
they actually
eight money they're not a fixed item but
and so diamonds are a gemstones are a
fixed item a supply shortage of those
drives the rarity of them drives the
price up yeah well I can remember in Oh
seven through nine the whole talk of
gold okay that that became you know
people were you know I need to buy gold
I need to buy gold I'm thinking no you
don't that's that's that's a the value
is man gifted there you go you know math
it's not math you could not roll into a
grocery store with a gold nugget and get
anything no
and so he's arresting yes but it's it's
I'd never heard of oil being at almost
zero yeah that's that's that blows my
mind yeah it's probably gonna take some
of the folks you work with on fox
business maria and those guys their
heads are probably exploding oh now yeah
because it's very unusual anomaly but it
has to do with the supply extra supply
the spigot got turned on by russia and
iran because they wouldn't observe the
cartels limitations mm-hmm
and the but they couldn't control the
supply and demand and so you know and
then everybody quit driving so there's
this huge oversupply of oil it's
everywhere versus a shortage of it would
drive the price up i mean i've seen oil
prices approach $200 a barrel mhm and
now it's down to a penny i mean it
usually hovers around the hundred or so
you know in that range or in the last
few years anyway but oh my gosh I mean
just supply supply supply supply I
wonder what else were not using that
there's a huge oversupply of or a
shortage of that we are overusing right
now you know I mean the things that
America's are consuming because they're
at home right the things they aren't
consuming because they're at home what
else it's going to do because that
that's really what this is it's a supply
demand curve the demand has either
greatly increased or greatly diminished
its greatly increased for delivering
things to your home right it's greatly
diminished for eating in a restaurant
none of them are open that's right you
know and that's gonna impact the
restaurant market
severely and you know those that are out
there that are smart enough I talked to
a few of them Dave that are plugged into
our entree leadership which is our
leadership and business owner
information at leader untrained
leadership calm but these restaurant
owners have been smart they pivoted
where they can't have people eating in
the restaurant but they're delivering
food to people that they can cook in
their homes and that's necessary several
of my friends at owned restaurants and
our chefs and so forth are doing all
kinds of stuff right now pivoting to
cause that to happen so that's what's
happening with the market out there
there's some other things in the news
Chris and I'll get to today a lot of the
people having their stimulus payments
scarfed up by debt collectors mmm
something we probably ought to talk
about yeah in that I don't think that
was the intention of the American
taxpayer going another two trillion
dollars into debt for the American
taxpayer I don't feel stimulated or
they're just not feeling stimulate it's
a problem it's just a problem